ich werde kein rockstar ich werde eine
legende sein
versprach er und hielt wort
heuer wäre freddie mercury 75 geworden
nun steht sein 30 todestag an
[Musik]
war der liebenswerteste zum nächsten
jahr als die freund wünschen kann und
er bleibt für heutige junge ein vorbild
sexueller selbstermächtigung
eigentlich einfach mitreißend und
ausdrucksstark und
vor allem in riburg aminati natürlich
auf spurensuche dort wo mercury
wiederholt lebte und wirkte in motril
[Musik]
in jungen jahren habe ich vor allem
grunge rock und trip hop gehört und bei
meiner musikalischen prägung waren queen
auch immer irgendwie mit dabei
wahrscheinlich war da lag es einfach an
facettenreichtum ihres sounds vor allem
ihr letztes album mit freddie mercury
welches hier in montreux vollendet wurde
hat es mir angetan und mich durch meine
teenager jahre begleitet das war made in
heaven herzlich willkommen bei kultur
[Musik]
das hier ist lucia müller als guide
führt der clean fans aus aller welt
durch montreux und heute nimmt er mich
mit
herzlich willkommen
wir sind hier neben freddy mercury die
stadt wir haben die bandmitglieder von
queen der stadt 1996 geschenken wie ist
dieser tag hier in montreux im
kollektiven gedächtnis haften geblieben
leider regnete es doch es gab enorm
viele gäste darunter die musiker
verkaufen
also dass schlagzeuger und der gitarrist
anwesend waren aber auch der manager der
band oder sängerin noa dabei eher
hat hier gelebt er hat hier gearbeitet
unter anderem sechs studioalben gemacht
warum ist er genau nach montreux
gekommen
das war wegen der morgen studios dem
casino von montreux ihre tore öffnete in
einem morast iju die band hat sie gar
1979 gekauft ein jahr nach ihrem ersten
besuch hier
zu jung sie sind mit jahrgang 83 nach
mir geboren
etwas später genau
deshalb machen sie diese führungen durch
nach dem aufbau der staat will er fand
mir meine eltern einen jährlichen anlass
mit dem ziel die fans aus aller welt
hier zu vereinen wenn sie freddie
mercury gedenken wollen
ich habe von ihnen die organisation
übernommen
dabei stellte ich fest dass viele
besucherinnen und besucher mit höchst
die geschichte zwischen queen und im ort
gar nicht kennen
so kam ich auf die idee touren
durchzuführen
das erste was man sieht ist diese statue
wenn man sie so anschaut ja da kann man
sich gerade vorstellen wie diese energie
bei dieser legendären pose zwischen
freddy und sein publikum hin und her
geschwankt ist
frontman mercury testosteron
versprühende die war
privatmann freddy tausendfach im netz
ein katzenfell
die rock-legende liebte oper ballett und
männer
offiziell lautet mercury sich nie die
liebe seines lebens war diese frau mary
der star der gegensätze
[Applaus]
er war der komplex ist doch einfachste
mann den ich je kennen lernte eine
wimmelt
peter fries ton hat über ein jahrzehnt
für den star eingekauft gekocht war
merkels persönliche assistenz mädchen
für alles und mit jeder facette des
senders vertraut
[Musik]
der traum wenn er zu hause war unter
freunden
war er toll
eine stimmungskanone
aber wenn man ihm fremde vorstellte
wurde eher scheu und unsicher
kennengelernt haben sich die beiden
1979 im royal opera house in london
der rock musiker trat einmalig mit den
königlichen ballett aus
riestern arbeitete als garderobe
nach der schon im hinter der bühne
einfach sagen dass es himmlisch gewesen
war
er war unglaublich
das hätte ich nicht erwartet
rockstar
etwa eine woche später wifi hand von
queen management man in boss an und
fragt ob ich mich für sechs wochen auf
einer tournee und die band kostüme
kümmern
das fünfminütige treffen mit fred hat
funktioniert
[Musik]
restore blieb an merkels seite bis zum
bitteren ende
rückblick
1970 studierte grafikdesigner leadsänger
von cool
mit killer queen auf dem album scheer
hatte tag schafft die band den
internationalen durchbruch und ist zu
gast in der tv sendung top of the pops
[Musik]
doch die musiker haben schulden das
ändert sich erst mit bohemian rhapsody
leider ging ob ein meilenstein
jetzt wo endlich geld fließt beschließt
die band dem astronomischen steuersatz
großbritanniens zu entfliehen
das clean up ende der 1970 er jahre
vorwiegend in montreux und münchen songs
einspielt lässt regisseur bryan singer
in doha mühelos city nur anklingen
montreal ist der ganz außen vor münchen
spielt im film eine winzige rolle
letzteres zum ärger von nicola dollar
zürcher und seit 40 jahren wahl-münchner
eben ist sein buch mercury in münchen
erschienen in dem er jene zeit bis ins
detail rekonstruiert die geschichte von
queen und mercury aber auch umfassender
beleuchtet ein beachtliches werk
mögliche ist der hauptwohnsitz vorrätig
sie von intermune
768 quryna die welt brauche
beispielsweise in oregon belaste ich die
erfolgreichste single erfolge wie ich an
als bohemian rhapsody und die alle
stufen haben in münchen die musical
dance studios
crazy little thing called love und die
scharia ist steht für quick 7 usd
die musicland studios im keller des
münchner arabella hauses verewigte queen
in video homevision
hier entwickelte sich eine
zusammenarbeit die für die musikalische
entwicklung der bahn von bedeutung war
mit tonmeister reinhold mack
[Musik]
ebenfalls nach mercurys geschmack
münchens nachtleben im gegensatz zum ort
feierte er hier ausschweifend etwa
seinen 39 geburtstag
[Musik]
die party dokumentiert den video zum
song living on a dieser ist auf seinen
einzigen solo album zu finden produziert
in münchen
mercury lebte damals mit dem wird wenig
irrig berger zusammen ließ es aber gerne
mit busenfreundinnen der schauspielerin
barbara valentin krachen neben barrios
denn die zweite wichtige frau
es geht eben verschiedene eu sorge ob
sie auch sexuelle pc also benötigt für
den zivis durch und trotzdem hat autos
boote oder ari sexueller hinsicht die
hosen nordhessen ist der beste ort für
die sich vom alkohol werden statt von
den aufnahmen gearbeitet wofür
eigentlich
natürlich
werde ich sage mal ins studio zu bruch
und hippies im studio geht und welchen
control room und die boote und hat
gehört und gesagt du bist spitze lädt
die nacht in einer mülltonne gebracht er
hat schon übertrieben ganz klar das ist
hans g die münchner jahre eine
zerreißprobe für die band
[Musik]
akribisch geübt wurde aber für das live
aid konzert 1985 der auftritt im wembley
stadion ein höhepunkt der rockgeschichte
[Musik]
ein jahr später selber ort der gag ist
einer der letzten von queen mit freddie
mercury
mercury ist hiv positiv dass er sich
angesteckt hat eröffnet er seinem
assistenten unter vier augen
er sagte im etwa zu mir
ich habe aids
dass dies ist das erste und letzte mal
dass wir darüber sprechen denn ich habe
ein leben zu leben
[Musik]
ein kurzes von seiner krankheit
gezeichnet dreht natori im mai 1991 noch
dieses video und sind den montreux mit
letzter kraft songs ein die erst postum
abgemischt werden
[Musik]
als mercury wenige stunden vor seinem
tod die aids erkrankung öffentlich
bestätigt wacht free stone am sterbebett
[Musik]
ich habe ihn nie
nie in die ganzen zwölf jahren in
österreich
so entspannt sind noch
so lang
am 24 november 1991 verliert die welt
einen begnadeten künstler
[Musik]
die mercury war der liebenswerteste
großzügigste
loyalsten mensch den man sich vorstellen
kann
ich setze mich unglaublich glücklich
dass ich einer war seinen freunden war
[Musik]
das hier ist die queen tribute
hier verewigen sich seit jahren die
queen fans und diese mauer führt uns zum
museum queen des studio experience
eröffnet wurde es am welt-aids-tag
2013 der eintritt ist frei spenden aber
gehen direkt an den mercury phoenix
trust womit man den kampf gegen die
krankheit aids unterstützt
[Musik]
das ist das kostüm dass freddy mercury
im wembley-stadion
1986 trikot und eines seiner berühmten
mikrofone mit kurzem ständer mit denen
er so gerne gespielt das war eine
besonderheit
eine karitative organisation die
bandmitglieder und der manager von queen
haben sie kurz nach freddys tod
gegründet sie arbeiten mit dem casino
zusammen dass die räumlichkeiten zur
verfügung stellt hier befanden sich
einst die morgen studios von trust
wiederum stammen die erinnerungsstücke
die queen mitglieder waren bei der
eröffnung hier
nicht während der eröffnung 2013 da kam
die bandmitglieder ja extra hier und ich
weiß dass sie bis heute ziemlich
regelmäßig nach motor
haben sie sie hier also schon getroffen
hier habe ich sie nie gesehen doch mein
vater hatte die gelegenheit sich hin zu
lernen
[Musik]
zug wem gehört seit jeher eine marketing
maschine vom t-shirt über teetassen bis
zum museum läuft noch immer im juni will
queen das zürcher hallenstadion füllen
bereits im januar kommt das musical we
will rock you in die schweiz uns schon
jetzt gibt's queen auf schweizerdeutsch
freddy die mundart show wagt sich im
zürcher theater hechtplatz an das
repertoire und will bald auf tournee
[Musik]
green auf schweizerdeutsch mutig
das secondhand orchestra wagt sich an
die höchst anspruchsvollen queen
arrangements stellt sich mercurys viel
gepriesenen stimmumfang
[Musik]
kommt ein mensch
zu sein dachte er an ihre gäste gut weil
ich die die tiefe töne von frankie say
again ist mir sehr wichtig und man in
der not die höhere den singenden denn
seit der größer ist als
verzehnfachen stabilität intensiv
[Musik]
und art show ist kein körper abend nebst
übersetzungen diverse hits
haben die vier eigene songs geschrieben
die
nehmen sich etwa parodistisch freddys
prägnanter zahnstellung an
[Musik]
dazwischen ein spiel gestaltet vom
pensionierten radiomoderator f dem
françois mürner der früher in england
lebte 170 oder audio ports und green
spielt im sandigen
birner erklärt zum beispiel warum
bohemian rhapsody ein hit werden konnte
der epische song galt eigentlich als
radio untauglich doch kein freund
mercurys spielte den sechs minuten als
erster ohne absprache mit dem chef
ferner zog nach
wenn man bisher nicht und das gefühl in
buchheim sofort merkt dass ich ein
meisterwerk und da sind uns die kunden
gehört
des chief operating lease gespielt hat
ein buch genannt und mir ist
es real life entfernten sie schon die
erste ziehen am tau wie hat er sofort
mitgeschnitten und ein paar tage später
verboten wiesen minis an die kinder
toben ist nicht gemacht hat hat die mit
job nicht gemacht aber
das meisterwerk schuf merkels
ursprünglich drei songs in
wochenlanger arbeit wurden mehrstimmiger
harmonien under gelagert
zudem war das video einer der ersten
musikclips überhaupt
bohemian rhapsody machte die bernd reich
[Musik]
nun hat roman riklin text auf
schweizerdeutsch übersetzt um dem
publikum die bedeutung näher zu bringen
[Musik]
ich glaube dass du eine übersicht über
prägen eine andere sprache passiert wenn
auch fremdes effekt womöglich krediten
sagen wir noch mal neu zu apple
wahrscheinlich ist ziel und so dem
rätselhaften inhalt auf die spur zu
kommen
[Musik]
der theorie war religiös geprägt
homosexualität war eine sünde
regeln hat recherchiert
liedinterpretation studiert und
letztlich mit einer sympathisiert
für ihn ist sakrosankt
bohemian rhapsody ist der größte
coming-out song der musikgeschichte
die adressatin
freddys mutter
bereits wochen sind die 60 euro indirekt
oskar ritter familie hätten sich nicht
getraut über das wetter und über die
zwiebel und das verurteilt werden von
den verschiedenen religionen und wenn er
über das sinkt und das versteckt die art
von konsum wird auf den punkt bringt das
ist großartig
[Musik]
green auf dialekt was sich wie ein
sakrileg anhört entpuppt sich im theater
als stimmiges experiment
das hier ist also ihr lieblingsplatz
ja wir sind hier im kontrollraum der
damaligen marken studios er wurde
originalgetreu wieder aufgebaut
[Musik]
hier haben wir eine rekonstruktion des
berühmten
es war das kernstück der studios einst
eine der besten aufnahmeort dem weltweit
gelten
das hat die queen nach not gebracht
hier haben wir eine erinnerungsplakette
am boden sie markiert den ort wo freddys
ein letztes lied ein sand mandala
es figuriert auf dem album medien hemmen
dass sie es war nur eine attrappe hier
im museum aber ich kann jetzt model of
mission der letzte song quasi der freddy
mich ganz zu ende singen konnte
nicht das ich könnte
[Musik]
gleich sind
die fielmann ag
[Musik]
mailand
wien gibt's als band noch sie füllen
staaten auch ohne freddie mercury aber
seine strahlkraft die wirkt bis heute
selbst bei jungen menschen die nach
seinem tod geboren wurden was hat er
ihnen noch zu sagen auch im hinblick auf
den umgang mit der eigenen sexualität
das wollten wir wissen und unser
jüngstes redaktionsmitglied aline
lakatos hat sich deshalb in der
community umgehört
[Musik]
täglich bezeichnet der freddy mercury
hat welche sprachen ist der stereotype
rollenverteilung für die geschlachtet
das betont aus burg virus auf das auch
bei meiner recherche stoß es läuft in
seiner für sexuelle selbstbestimmung
kritik ich habe aber nie öffentlich zu
seiner homosexualität stand ein
widerspruch
ich drifte lorenzaccio in der
kunsthochschule basel als auch auf meine
recherche aufruf in der sozialen medien
wollte
am tag studierte modedesign und nachts
von ta als dragqueen
die homosexualität offen aus was auch
der freddy mercury zu seiner zeit
vielleicht nur geklaut hat
dreck macht herbert k wo ich als freund
maximilian
und der versuch eine entschuldigung
sitzung
sowie
lorenz und sind die community hat ihn
also schon früher als homosexuelle
künstler work no und glaube gewisse
spieler entdeckt
sie als geheimagent
begriffe und soll ich sie klinisch
frieden herablassen der schwule männer
gestanden als provokant spiel mit
betriebs- und vollständige
video zur abstimmung für das kollektiv
hinter dem projekt hat unter anderem
want to break free greengrass will sich
nämlich für klassische geschlechterrolle
lösen damit liege heimann verzählt als
tracking ist es üblich ab und zu mancher
dragqueen
stelle weiter und sind als ikone und
vorbild für community ist mitunter sehr
bewusste wahl gesehen deswegen aber auch
vom inhalt ein lyrisch
wie
statt dass man sie wenn man ist
vor 30 jahren freddie mercury an aids
gestorben für ihn und ganz viele
menschen sind zb
sensibilisierungskampagne
die schweiz kein direktes vorbild zu
freddie mac
enthält die für sichere generation
ausgelöst worden ist durch die krise und
mehr deswegen sehr viele wichtige
vorbilder muss der boomer generation
endlich im handel
freddie mercury immer neuer strahlkraft
sind stelle war ist unbestritten
in die community aber auch für viele
andere mannschaft
vor allem ist eine re zieht was ich
vieles schnell verändert und wo mir für
viele lacher wenn die stadt sind die
sachen von er verkörpert und die energie
war er ausstrahlt sache gut verbindet
und mehrweg losbrach und vereine das
hätte freddie mac schafft auch ohne
explizit com laut
[Musik]
das ostufer des genfersees der ort mit
dem ich freddie mercury verbinde
weil es diese sicht auf das cover seines
letzten albums geschafft hat wie erwähnt
made in heaven
[Musik]
die tickets schwierige fragen schluss
welches ist für sie freddie mercury
vermächtnis es ist ein enormes
seine musik seine außergewöhnliche
stimme
besonders die vielfalt an der songs die
er und kühlen komponiert haben
ich denke die leute werden noch lange
diese musik hören
dieses unglaublich werk von freddy quinn
schätzen
danke dass sie mich heute begleitet
haben und ihnen natürlich auch
herzlichen dank fürs mit kommen hier auf
sf1 geht es jetzt weiter mit der
sternstunde kunst und kubrick bei
kubrick und nächste woche geht es bei
uns beim kulturplatz weiter mit frauen
in einer besonderen phase zur
lebensmitte sie werden sehen
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
des westens
[Applaus]